as the war enters a new phase the skies
above Ukraine are becoming increasingly
crowded
Radars and air defenses are designed to
detect and Destroy enemy aircraft and
missiles but a complex mix of drones
cruise missiles helicopters aircraft
ballistic and Hypersonic missiles means
that even the most advanced air defenses
are struggling to cope
Russia has learned Several Hard lessons
in this war long-range Ukrainian fire
from high Mars has forced Russia to move
its command centers fuel Depots and
ammunition dumps further back from the
front lines out of range from high Mars
Precision strikes Russia is also using
spotter drones to better affect its
artillery batteries are more responsive
and more difficult for Ukrainian units
to destroy
recent strikes on Cave have been
conducted in part to test the limits of
advanced air defense batteries such as
the Patriot
Russia launched a wide range of missiles
the Patrick batteries destroyed most of
them but not before it was damaged now
Ukraine 2 has a potent new weapon the
Storm Shadow with more than triple the
range of high Mars This stealthy cruise
missile can deliver a 480 kilogram
Warhead with high precision
the tandem charge able to First breach
and then enter and Destroy World
protected targets such as command posts
and underground bunkers
Ukraine's long-range fire will focus on
wearing down Russia's ability to
resupply its forces in an attempt to
leave them vulnerable the Storm Shadow
is a valuable addition to the Ukrainian
Arsenal giving its troops the ability to
destroy high-value targets far behind
the front lines